un tout autre sujet maintenant tintin
chez le psychanalyste et oui c'est un
livre que vient de publier serge
tisseron et qui passionnera aussi bien
les fanatiques de tintin de milou et du
capitaine haddock que tous ceux qui
s'intéressent à la psychanalyse car ce
livre très sérieux on peut le dire a été
écrit par un médecin psychanalyste voici
ce livre serge tisseron donc qui est
notre invité alors avant d'en discuter
plus avec vous serge tisseron
on va prendre quelques exemples avec
monique atlan voici les premiers albums
de tintin vous allez les détails et en
commençant par tintin au congo des
tintin au congo
hergé commence effectivement par créer
deux personnages et ce à quoi il va
s'attacher c'est à nous montrer les
relations entre ces deux personnages
entre tintin et milou en les voyant par
exemple ici partir tous les deux pour le
congo dans le premier album et hergé va
donc s'attacher dans cet album à nous
montrer toutes les séparations et puis
toutes les retrouvailles de ces deux
héros et ce qui est importante par
exemple ici nous voyons milou qui est
menacée par un crocodile ou ici par en
bois ou encore ici en nous voyant 1,5 et
menacé par ron buffle ou par un éléphant
et ce qui est important c'est que lors
de toutes ces séparations chacun encore
ne pense d'abord qu'à sauver sa peau par
exemple sur cette vignette à la fin du
congo on voit milou qui s'enfuit dans un
trou et au contraire tintin qui se
cramponne à une échelle de corde envoyé
par un avion
or ça c'est quelque chose qui va
complètement changer dans les albums qui
suivent en particulier dans interne
amérique parce que à partir de là chaque
chacun des deux c'est à dire à la fois
tintin et milou va penser à l'autre
donc c'est d'abord tintin que nous
voyons ici penser à milou en prison et
puis ensuite milou va se mettre à penser
à tintin d'abord on va le voir ici se
préoccupait de tintin dire par exemple
comme vous voyez
pourvu qu'il ne soit pas arrivé malheur
à tintin
et puis bientôt milou va lui même pensé
au visage de tintin comme dans cette
vignette ou dans sept autres et à ce
moment là
tintin et milou vont vraiment devenir
les deux inséparables qu'ils sont dans
la suite des aventures
c'est là que la doc à paris we had hoc
dès le début et d'un personnage
préoccupé par son ancêtre le chevalier
c'est à dire que je lis j'ai été étonné
de voir qu'en fait il n'y a pas un ado
qu'il y en ait deux lits à haddock
quand il n'a pas bu et comme ici où il
parle avec tintin
et puis il y as haddock quand il a bu et
haddock quand il a bu hergé nous montre
qu'il n'est plus lui-même voyez il n'a
plus du tout le regard le même regard
que sur les autres vignettes et à ce
moment là en fait qui est il bien émergé
du monde qu'il est son ancêtre lui même
on le voit par exemple sur cette image
passé sa tête dans le portrait de
l'ancêtre et donc nous avons un
personnage double avec le visage du
capitaine haddock et le corps peint de
l'ancêtre dessous sur le portrait on a
une analyse très détaillée passionnante
en tout cas quel travail docteur